Nigel Farage has described it as an
earthquake in British politics but one
thing's for certain
last night's European results giving the
pollsters plenty to talk about so let's
grab two of them for you the chief
executive of pollsters it's awesome or
even Paige and political analyst from
nothing Universe Nottingham University I
can't get my words out professor Matthew
Goodwin we all know why Matthew east in
tech there you go let's let's see where
this leaves you guys and whether we were
a year to live till we go to the general
election is this gonna have any impact
or not been to you first of it it's
going to but you we still don't know in
exactly what way most people didn't vote
most people will vote at the general
election nevertheless it does suggest
that you keep damage both labour and the
Conservatives it makes a majority for
either of the bigger parties less like
it makes everything more uncertain and
absolutely one thing we can guarantee
whatever happens at the general election
it will be pretty historic in terms of
the possible outcomes Philip Hammond the
defense secretary who said he thought
that a lot of Tory voters simply lent
you Kip their vote Matthew is that right
I mean obviously you keep saying we've
got the votes we're gonna keep hold of
the moats but how does it pan out as far
as the general election is concerned
well we're going to see a lot of
comparisons now with 2009 when after the
European elections you kept support
completely crashed at the general
election there are good reasons to think
that will not happen to anywhere near
the same extent in 2015 one is law -
cross polling which which suggests one
in two you kick voters of the European
elections will stay loyal in 2015
the other is a nice resource that US
academics use a British election study
which suggests almost two-thirds of you
Kipp voters at the European elections
will also vote you Kipp at the general
election now those numbers are high but
anything about 7 percent next year
starts causing real problems for David
Cameron and the Conservatives what about
the targeting because obviously there's
been a pretty clear pattern emerge for
Nigel Farage in the local and the
Europeans and he's looked at at least
said it gives us a proper targeting
strategy now does that sort of targeting
as much as it might help you Kip
fizzy's actually benefit the other main
parties in areas where you keep aren't
going to fire
well the the you can't vote will
obviously be higher where they're
putting the real resources in but
nevertheless it's still an attractive
place to go if you're fed up if you're
concerned about immigration so they'll
get votes everywhere and that will also
lead to damage particularly to the
conservatives but they will pick up it
does look very likely there will be a
you Kipp MP but probably still fewer
than the poor old Lib Dems you've had a
horrible night last night let's talk
about the new Act by election next month
how telling will that be in how with
what we can expect in the election issue
in the European elections last night you
keep one Newark they finished first in
Newark and talking about the local hot
spots for you kick next year they pulled
over 40 percent in 30 local areas they
pulled over 50 percent in Boston so
looking at Boston and skegness Great
Yarmouth thorak these kinds of areas
also Plymouth important after Doncaster
you kept hold more votes and labor so
this is really uncharted territory they
also beat labour in Hartlepool which has
been labour territory since 1964 so this
is really really interesting as stuff
and as Ben says I mean you it's very
difficult to predict the impact of this
in 2015 for you guys though in terms of
what you do this must be a nightmare
mostly because a lot of polls that it's
not just a case of asking people what
they want to do you have to balance out
work out what sort of voters they work
for if they're living in one of the key
heartlands all that's out now isn't it
it does make the 2015 general election
extremely interesting the pollsters
particularly because the turnout factor
we just don't know how many of those
people as a general election who are
sort of interested in you Kip
actually get down to the polling station
compared to the other parties we have no
real history to go on so it's going to
be an absolute nail-biter I think in
well and and one of the things that we
have just done is we sat down and
analyzed UKIP's vote over a 10-year
period in a book that's just come out
and the conclusion I mean of that and
looking at the deeper trends in British
societies that this has been building
pretty much since the 1970s we've got a
section of the electorate that is
financially struggling that is
pessimistic that is disadvantaged that
feels cut out of our politics and this
isn't just about
clash to the 2010 general election and
coalition government it isn't just about
an EU referendum this is about far
deeper divisions within British society
in terms of those divisions then they
say I mean we heard someone saying
earlier on here there's been a long time
with a lot of social inclusion a lot you
know a love the idea of a mixed cultural
society we saw you know really developed
with New Labour back in the sort of late
90s early noughties a lot of people now
are clearly quite happy to say actually
I don't want any more immigration out
it's something they would have been
embarrassed to put their name to a few
years ago that clearly is having an
impact concern about immigration has
been at record levels now for the better
part of a decade and some months it's
seen as the biggest issue facing this
country 80% of people in Britain say
it's a big problem although only 18
percent say it's a problem where they
live and you know why this is
problematic for the Conservatives in
2015 because when you look at the UK
ploy list those who say I'm going to
stay with you Kip until the general
election
it's those you kick loyalists that are
most animated by immigration so the more
our political parties and leaders start
banging on about immigration the more
they risk strengthening the link between
Farraj and his core voters all between a
rock and a hard place and although been
Mathew great super thank you